hey welcome to the monitor I'm Peter
Rubin senior editor wired and this week
you know what's back oh we're going back
to Westeros y'all game of thrones Sunday
night on HBO season 3 of course
coincides with the third book in the
song of ice and fire series a storm of
swords which for many people is their
most loved book in the george RR martin
fantasy saga but when we come back we
finally meet Mance Rayder king of the
wildlings and he is bitching we've been
hearing his name for two years now we
finally get to meet him we don't see
everyone that we left him season two but
a lot of the primary characters are back
and there's a lot of nice agile
exposition that grounds us and where we
left off in season two but there's a lot
in store there's some new characters
coming and there is a lot of madness of
foot winter is coming in late March
Sunday night's HBO Game of Thrones talk
about a new comic book so this actually
happened last week on the very day we
taped last week's episode of the monitor
so so we didn't get in the show but want
to talk about it now so bryan cave on
comic book and television writer
extraordinaire he wrote y the last man
he's writing the fantastic saga series
right now he teamed up with artist
marcos martin and they said let's make a
comic book and let people pay what they
want and not have it be drm and just
have it be online only so that is what
they did the series of private i started
last week it is going to be a ten issue
maxi series you can pay what you want
you can download it in a variety of
formats its online only and it's great
it takes place in the near future and
some sort of info security lapses has
had everything made everything fall out
of the clouds everybody's personal
information has been exposed people
freaked out there's no more wireless
there's no more internet there's no more
networking in that sense it's a little
bit like the new battlestar galactica
but there is this paparazzo who was kind
of also a private eye and he digs up
information for people anonymity is
achieved by wearing these elaborate
holographic identities that people call
nims anyway the writing is great it's
littered with fantastic pop culture
references bryan cave vons writing is as
piquant as ever and great art by marcos
martin it is a great start the private
eye you have to go to panel syndicate
calm in order to pay what you like and
load it so do that but make it fair
support great independent comic book
story telling let's talk about video
games it's supposed to come out last
fall it was supposed to come out in
February it is finally out this week it
is bioshock infinite the third but
actually really the spiritual sequel to
the original bioshock because this is
also spearheaded by ken Levine and
irrational games the original BioShock
was there brainchild this takes place
not in the 50s not in an undersea place
but in a floating cloud city called
Columbia takes place in the 1910s and it
is this sprawling crazy political tale
of intrigue and xenophobia and a little
bit of magic and all kinds of craziness
it is by far one of the most creative
games of the past few years people been
freaking out about this I'm just glad it
lives up to the hype I was hoping to
have my copy by the time I tape this I
don't but I also edited februari issues
great feature on bioshock infinite so
you can read that if you need a bunch of
great exclusive background information
on what's going on at any rate out from
irrational games on 2k publisher yes yes
yes by that also fantastic music they
need to put out the soundtrack that's it
for the monitor this week we'll be back
next week with more pop culture goodness
but until then inspirational catchphrase
here